aquí nos dicen arrastra los deslizadores
y después nos dicen qué deslizador crea
copias a escala de la figura bueno vamos
a explorar esto un poco cada uno de
estos deslizadores cambian la figura de
diferentes formas entonces esta es la
figura ve si dejamos el deslizador en el
inicio podemos ver que el ancho es un
poco más grande que la altura bueno esto
es lo que observo a simple vista no
conocemos los números exactos entonces
para crear una copia a escala más bien
necesitamos escalar todos los lados al
mismo tiempo porque queremos escalar por
el mismo factor pero conforme
arrastramos el deslizador podemos ver
que solamente escala el ancho no la
altura por lo tanto este deslizador para
la figura ve no crea copias a escala
solamente incrementa el largo y no el
ancho mientras que en la figura
podemos ver que se incrementa tanto el
largo como el ancho por lo tanto podemos
decir
qué es una copia a escala por ejemplo
esa se ve como una copia a escala de
esto que a su vez es una copia a escala
de esto que a su vez es una copia a
escala de esto que es la figura original
mientras que ésta no es una copia a
escala de esto hagamos otro ejemplo
nuevamente nos dicen arrastra los
deslizadores y después que deslizador
crea copias a escala de la figura bueno
vamos con la figura y aquí podemos ver
que estamos escalando el largo y el
ancho por el mismo factor así que parece
ser que el deslizador a crea copias a
escala de la figura mientras que en el
caso b ahora sólo escalamos la altura
pero no el ancho así que no creamos
copias a escala de nuestra figura
original aquí solamente se incrementa su
altura pero no su ancho nos vemos en
otro vídeo